I was about to go to bed
when I realized that dinner just wasn't quite enough.
I've been craving kimchi chicken all day today.
It's so quick to make, so I made it before heading back to bed.
Started with my broth, which was some daikon, radish,
also half of a green onion,
like using the root part for my broth,
and some dried anchovies.
I took the head off and lucky helped me getting out all the guts
since they were on the smaller side.
And then filled my pot with some water and my green onion,
the anchovies
and daikon before letting that simmer for about 25 minutes.
While that was going,
I found some pork belly that I diced up before straining my broth.
Fried up my pork belly, added my chopped up kimchi
and let that saute for a minute before I added in my broth
some fermented red chili paste,
some chili flakes, a little bit of sugar,
sesame oil, salt,
some soy sauce, give that good mix.
And then added in some of my kimchi brine.
While that was going, I chopped up some green onion and also some tofu.
I let that simmer for another five minutes and then it was time to eat.
I always burn my tongue because I'm so impatient and I can't wait,
but this was so divine and exactly what I needed to put me to sleep.